so make Thank You Curt thanks very much
can everybody hear me okay okay how many
of you have been in a dark enough place
to see the sky a fair fraction okay but
not where you live probably right you
got to drive out in the country or
something yeah I think from new haven
you know we have a student observatory
up on edward street and you can probably
see the moon and maybe you can see a
planet or two but you can't see the sky
so the first thing I'm going to show you
is the sky let me make this nice and
dark okay weird I won't have all dark
for the whole time but I just want you
to be able to see this really well this
is a picture taken by the Hubble Space
Telescope it is one of the longest
exposures ever taken this one was about
ten days long almost everything you're
looking at is a galaxy a galaxy consists
of about a hundred billion stars and
each star is like our Sun so the light
you're seeing is from is sort of the
added up light from the stars you can't
see the individual stars in the in those
galaxies they're too far away but you
can see all the Starlight and before you
know before the world was as populated
as it is now people could go outside and
see this kind of thing every night you
know the skies were dark and I think in
those days people would wonder I'm going
to turn the lights back up in one second
so just hang there and yeah okay that's
good and and so you can you can you can
leave them up it's okay people used to
look at the sky and wonder you know what
is that stuff where is it and it often
had a resonance with the questions like
where did we come from today we're in a
different regime where we have very
sensitive telescopes and detectors and
we can find out an amazing
amount about the universe it's infected
it's mind-boggling how much we know it's
more mind-boggling how much remains to
be discovered so for the students in the
audience this is your job okay I'm going
to tell you today about the discovery of
dark energy but as I'll say at the end
we don't have a clue what this stuff is
it is the dominant constituent of the
universe most of the universe consists
of dark energy three-quarters of the
universe is dark energy we didn't even
know it existed until 1998 and we don't
know what it is and so I think there's a
lot of work for scientists if you if
you're interested in this subject
there's a lot of work for you in the
future okay um whoops sorry back up to
start I just want to give you a sense of
what we know about the universe we've
known for some years that it started as
a small point smaller than a smaller
than an atom and in the frak tiny
fraction of a second it expanded to
about the size of this room in a period
called inflation and then it's been
coasting ever since the universe is
expanding and what I'll tell you about
today is how we know it's expanding okay
and then how that the study of the
expansion of the universe led us to
discover dark energy and at any time if
there's something you don't understand
please put your hand up and tell me so
we can so I can answer your questions
along the way this cartoon is just
supposed to indicate that after this
initial Bang the Big Bang the universe
got very big and today it's huge and
filled with galaxies so I'm going to
tell you a little bit about about this
before we start I want to orient you to
the scale the size scale of the universe
the universe is really big and it's a
little hard well it's impossible to
contemplate frankly even for me but
let's try okay this is just a drawing so
at the lower right you see a picture of
the Hubble Space Telescope how many of
you recognize that that it's Hubble okay
hubble was launched in nineteen ninety
nineteen ninety and is still operating
so it's a pretty old by NASA standards
it's about the size of a school bus this
telescope is the size of a school bus
see these two astronauts those are
humans in up space suits it was as big
as you could make it and still launch it
on the space shuttle that's that's what
determine how big it was okay suppose I
multiply the size of the space telescope
by a factor of 1 million ok sorry Hubble
is about 10 meters long then I get to a
cube that encloses the earth in other
words the diameter of the earth is
roughly a million times the size of the
space telescope that's 10 to the seventh
meters how many of you study meters in
school parents did you study meters no
yes ok we were supposed to go to the
metric system once but that was a long
time ago it's hopeless ok so the earth
fits in this 10 million meter box now
i'm going to multiply by a million again
and i get to the size of the solar
system 10 to the 13th meters ok across
that number may not mean that much to
you but you can think of it as light
takes about 10 hours to get across the
solar system so sunlight for example
takes about 10 hours to get out to Pluto
which used to be the most distant planet
and is now is now a planet II know or
whatever ok multiply now by 10,000 and
you get to a box that encloses the
nearest few stars so these are stars
that are a few light-years from our Sun
that's very very local ok multiply by
another factor of 10,000 and you get to
the sides of our Milky Way galaxy our
Milky Way galaxy looks something like
this it's a spiral galaxy it's filled
with as I said 100 billion stars we live
kind of out in the suburbs this is we
live out in one of the spiral arms
pretty far
from the center of the galaxy that
galaxy is like a hundred thousand
light-years across so if I get on the
computer and I'm trying to IM with an
alien on the other side of the galaxy it
takes a hundred thousand years for my
signal to get over there and even if
they reply immediately it's another
hundred thousand years to get back so
we're not going to we're not going to be
I aming with them okay pretty big huh
for someone like me who works on larger
scales this is just totally local
neighborhood this is like your house
maybe your maybe the few blocks around
your house okay x a hundred and you get
a box that encloses the nearest few
galaxies there are other galaxies there
are actually billions of galaxies in our
universe and there are a few that are
near us maybe a total of about 50 of
which only one is as big as our galaxy
so Andromeda and the Milky Way are the
two big shots in our local Local Group
of galaxies ok one more multiplication
by factor of a thousand and now we're on
the scale of the universe and my talk
today is about this scale this this is
sort of 10 billion light years across so
the light from the first galaxies that
we can see took 10 billion years to get
to us ok any questions on that the
universe is big take take home lesson
number one ok ok let's talk about how we
know the universe is expanding and this
is a story that leads to the discovery
of dark energy we can come back and talk
about this it's not like a balloon
expanding when you blow it up because
that is that's the balloon expanding
while space is staying the same sort of
when I say the universe is expanding I
mean space itself
okay so if you imagine space space is
completely empty but you imagine it has
sort of a coordinate system on it the
distance between any two points is
growing with time you don't notice that
in your daily life because barley
because it's not happening near you
because other effects are stronger like
gravity but in our universe we can
observe the effects of this expansion
okay we the way we observe the effects
of expansion I'm going to let you look
at this picture too because it's really
pretty we look at galaxies so here's a
picture where you can very clearly see
some big galaxies here's a this is a
spiral galaxies like ours this is a sort
of a disk II galaxy this is a very round
galaxy here's a weirdo one you can look
at these galaxies and you can measure
how how they're moving with respect to
us this is what astronomers did a
hundred years ago and the way they did
it was to use a technique I'm going to
explain in a second about Doppler shifts
so I'm going to teach you about the
Hubble law this was determined by Edwin
Edwin Hubble after whom then telescope
is named and he found that the speed
with which galaxies are moving away from
us is proportional to their distance so
the nearest galaxies are moving away
slowly the more distant galaxies are
moving away much faster and he concluded
that this meant the universe was
expanding and I'm going to explain this
whole story to you ok so I'm going to
explain what the Hubble law is I'm going
to explain how we measure the speed with
which a galaxy is moving away I'm going
to tell you how we measure its distance
so far so good ok let's talk about
distance if I had a light bulb and I
know exactly how bright it is it's a
hundred watts say and I move it two
times farther away from me it should be
four times dimmer it will be four times
dimmer if I move it ten times farther
away it'll be a hundred times dimmer
this is this is an empirical observation
that you can
you can test yourself it basically means
it that but it's really easy to
understand if you have light going out
in all three dimensions then you can
think of a sort of a shell of light
covering a sphere the surface area of a
sphere is 4 PI R squared okay so it so
you spread the light over a surface
that's 4 PI R squared so as you go
farther and farther out the surface is
bigger the light is dimmer by that
factor of R squared okay so if you could
measure how bright something appears and
if you thought you knew its luminosity
that means how how bright it truly is
that is it is it a hundred watt light
bulb or something else then you can
infer the distance okay you measure the
brightness and the luminosity you know
the luminosity and you measure the
distance if you know the luminosity we
call an object a standard candle it just
means that we know how bright it is and
therefore we can use it to drive
distance you sort of know what this is
like if you if you think about a street
set of streetlights here's a picture of
one the near ones are bright and the
more distant ones are dimmer even though
they're all more or less the same
brightness so if I if I measure their
brightness 'as i can tell where the
lights are situated clear okay that's
how that's one of the ways we measure
the distance to other galaxies and to
supernovae which I'll talk about in a
moment okay this is a little more
complicated to measure the speed with
which a galaxy is receding from us we
measure something called the redshift
and to understand redshift you have to
understand spectra so you are probably
familiar with rainbows the light in this
room at which we call white light
actually consists of light of all
different wavelengths from red to blue
red yellow green blue just like this
spectrum on the top
if we have sophisticated instruments we
can measure how much light is B is
contained in some light bulb or the Sun
or these lights as a function of their
wavelength and we call that a spectrum
so that's what this is it's the
intensity of light as a function of the
wavelength of that light and the blue
curve is just my sketch of what a
spectrum might look like okay you might
see a lot of light at some wavelengths
and a deficit of light at other
wavelengths and these are characteristic
of certain atomic transitions for
different kinds of atoms for example in
the Sun there are hundreds and hundreds
of these absorption lines caused by
atoms in the atmosphere of the Sun now
why this is important for our story
today is because if you look at the
light from distant galaxies it's shifted
with respect to the light from our own
galaxy that is the wavelength at which
these lines appear shift and it shifts
to the red if the galaxy is moving away
from us so if I see the same
characteristic spectrum but it's shifted
to the red this distance between the
wavelength change of the light tells me
how quickly it's receding we define
something called the red shift Z that's
a symbol for red shift which is just the
change in the wavelength from where it
ought to be locally to where it is in
these galaxies / that wavelength that's
called the redshift and it measures the
speed with which that galaxy appears to
be moving away really what it's
measuring is the expansion of space so
this is called a Doppler shift how many
of you have ever heard of a Doppler
shift okay so i'm going to show you an
example of a Doppler shift which I found
online okay let's do this
ok you heard when the car was coming
toward us you heard it was high-pitched
sound was going away as a low pitch down
I'll do that one more time don't do this
at home
that shift in the frequency of sound is
analogous to the shift in the frequent
the wavelength of light that I'm telling
you about and just to kind of let me
just show you a sort of the same kind of
thing but now these guys in this wait
are you playing yes play see the
shooting remember that note here it's
higher can you hear that
and now it's lower okay what I like
about that video is you hear the horn
when it's not moving so you can hear
that in the middle right when it comes
towards you it's shifted to higher
frequency when it goes away it shifted
to lower frequency light does the same
thing when it's coming toward us we say
it's blue shifted because it shifted to
higher frequency or shorter wavelength
and when it's moving away from us we say
it's red shifted because it shifted to
longer wavelength or lower frequency
okay let's go back to our slide okay
okay so a hundred years ago this guy
vest o Slifer unfortunate man named wise
but otherwise pretty clever observed a
bunch of galaxies and he he was
observing the galaxies in our
neighborhood and he observed that most
of them are moving away from us okay so
if a galaxy is let's just look at this
galaxy if this galaxy is moving away
from us then we'll see its spectrum
shifted to longer wavelengths okay
that's how he could tell i mean he's
measured the longer wavelengths and if
it's moving toward us then we'll see it
shifted to shorter wavelengths a blue
ship and he was able to say that of the
30 or so galaxies nearby almost every
one of them was moving away one or two
were moving toward us now this was very
disconcerting imagine who wants to be
the center of the universe I need
somebody in the middle to raise their
hand okay you could be the center of the
universe imagine that everybody takes a
big step away from you you would feel
special but not in a good way right it's
like why are you the center of the
universe I mean we live on earth Earth's
an ordinary planet around an ordinary
star in an ordinary galaxy why should
everybody be moving away from us it
seemed for a moment to imply that we
were special and this harked back to the
pre Copernican days when we used to
think we were the center of the universe
and then we figured out that the Sun was
the you know we were going around the
Sun
the other way around and then we realize
later the sun's only one star in a big
galaxy and but now we seem to be moving
backwards galaxies are moving away from
us why well Hubble was the guy who had
the clever idea about this Hubble said
ok I know that most galaxies are moving
away from us I also can see that the
more distant galaxies are moving away
faster and he had a clever idea that
this suggests the universe is expanding
now to me that was not obvious I don't
know how Hubble got it but to me it was
not obvious so I'm going to explain it
to you ok that's that's the Hubble law
speed proportional to distance here's
his actual plot this is the speed of
galaxies as a function of their distance
from us from the Milky Way galaxy is a
plot and you can see the data points or
those dark point and the line just shows
you the trend in the data and that trend
describes the Hubble law the more
distant galaxies are moving faster this
is 25 35 thousand kilometers per second
that's pretty fast pretty huge expansion
ok here's here's why this works I'm
making a fake universe here imagine that
there's a infinite space and I've made a
perfectly regular grid and at every grid
point I've put a galaxy this isn't how
space really is galaxies are kind of
random but ok I put a Galaxy at every
grid point and maybe I'll turn the
lights down for this one too I've
circled some galaxies so I'm going to
pick this one arbitrarily to be the
center of the universe ok just for now
let's look at that galaxy and I've got
three galaxies that are one tick mark
away I've colored them light blue the
galaxies that are to tick marks away or
like green and here's one
three tick marks away it's in yellow
okay now just watch what happens when I
magically have space expand by thirty
percent okay what happens is every grid
point gets the separation between grid
points gets bigger by thirty percent and
now you oh sorry back up back up back up
this one you see that this distance now
is thirty percent bigger than it was the
galaxies themselves by the way don't get
bigger and you can ask me why later okay
so let's calculate the change in
distance between adjacent grid points so
the two nearest points are now separated
by thirty percent more distance than
they were so I'm just going to call the
distance D so its 1.3 d minus 1 d is
what gives me how much it moved it moved
point 3d everybody got that and it turn
the lights back on so i can see you when
you say yes or no okay how about the
galaxies that were two gridmarx away
well now there are two point six apart
and they were too so they move point six
and the ones that were three squares
apart move point nine okay now who knows
how you measure speed distance yeah
what's the answer anybody distance over
x she's got it distance over time so
let's let's calculate the speed each of
these galaxies move that much in the
same time okay so whatever that time was
let me call that speed V because V is
velocity in physics and the the point
that was farther apart moves at twice
the speed and then three times the speed
can you see that so let me make a plot
of this let me plot Hubble's law I plot
the speed of the galaxy vs its distance
away from the one that I picked to be
the center of the universe and you can
see that
they make a Hubble law the speed of
recession of galaxies from that one that
I picked is proportional to the distance
I could have picked any galaxy in that
grid okay I didn't have to be the one I
picked I could have picked any other
galaxies and it too would have behaved
like the galaxy with cooties okay
because every galaxy is moving away from
every other galaxy and that's a
consequence of the expansion of space so
Hubble Hubble's idea of the expansion of
space fixed the the problem that we look
special we aren't special we're not in
any special location every galaxy sees
every other galaxy moving away from it
questions about that yeah so at the time
they were using the 100-inch telescope
on Mount Wilson in California it's a
hundred inches is like three meters it's
a 33 yards it's pretty big and that was
the biggest telescope at the time it's
now utterly useless because Mount Wilson
is too close to Los Angeles and the
skies are too bright you can't do
anything there I'm going to I'm going to
illustrate this expansion because this
is a really key concept with some
volunteers I need like five or six kids
to come up front come on up come on up
come on up come on up how are we doing
go ahead you can come too that looks
like the right number come up and line
up here I want you to hold hands I want
you to get in the middle of this desk
like like spread-out like next to each
other I know so you're like shoulders
are touching can you get really close
and let's make sure you're kind of in
the middle yeah that's pretty good okay
this is our current universe who wants
to be the center of the universe you do
okay you win you're going to stay right
there okay everybody else is going to
move so that you're in arm lengths away
from the person next to you okay so
stick your arm out and move until you're
an arm lengths away from the person next
to you keep moving let's go arms out I
looking good okay who moved the farthest
away
he moved a lot farther he was really
fast and you were kind of you didn't
move at all and you were you guys were
equally slow right because you didn't
have to move so far but all but if space
is expanding then everybody has to move
apart from everybody else well done we
have a round of applause for our
demonstration thank you you guys think
of them thanks you can do that at home
that is not a dangerous experiment okay
Hubble diagram this is what Hubble did
I'm now I'm going to tell you about
modern measurements of the Hubble
diagram for which we use lots of
different instruments but Hubble the
Hubble Space Telescope is one of them
for example for some reason in the
modern day we flip this diagram so
instead of speed versus distance we plot
sorry back up we plot distance versus
speed and remember speed I measure from
the red shift so i have to take a
spectrum of a galaxy and I measure the
distance from the galaxy's brightness ok
so at this end it's small red shift at
that end it's a big red shift down here
the objects are bright farther up there
they're dim ok now this is a key concept
the expansion of the universe should be
slowing down I'm telling you that can
anybody imagine why that might be yes
oh okay but that but it could keep going
forever if it did that right you have
more space but it could keep going from
further is there anything that could be
pulling it back yes gravity gravity
there are a lot of galaxies in the
universe galaxies exert gravitational
force on each other actually each of you
is exerting a gravitational force on
your neighbor and on everyone else
actually and on me but it's a very weak
force however if you had 10 billion
stars it gets a bit stronger okay so
it's a strong force gravity it's very
heavy gravity should be slowing down the
expansion and in the 1990s astronomers
astronomers had more or less figured out
the whole universe now you know because
I told you that they didn't know about
dark energy this is completely untrue
okay but they thought they'd figured
everything out and the one missing piece
was how much mass there was in the
universe how much stuff how much matter
and they realized that by measuring the
rate at which the expansion is slowing
down they could figure out how much
matter was in the universe if the
slowing down is very dramatic then
there's a lot of gravity so there's a
lot of matter if it's not slowing down
much at all then there isn't very much
matter and all they had to do is measure
that rate of deceleration of the
expansion of the universe okay do people
see that that the amount of matter will
more matter slows it down more okay so
here's our Hubble diagram distance
versus speed if if this is this Hubble
law works for a constant speed of
expansion that means in every part of
universe that every time the expansion
is the same then you get this straight
line but if the expansion is
decelerating then objects are a little
bit closer than they would otherwise be
okay constant expansion they're going
out but if it's
slowing down that very distant galaxy is
just a little bit closer and so it's a
little bit brighter so it's a little bit
lower on this axis okay so if I could
measure galaxies / really far away I
should see that they're slowing down and
they should follow this curve they
should not be a straight line they
should follow this curve that's what
astronomers were trying to measure and
the way they usually plot this oh yeah
right object objects are closer and
they're brighter therefore they usually
plot this by D trending it so they just
take out the linear Hubble trend and
they plot how much above or below this
line points are okay are they brighter
than the uniform expansion in which case
they're below or are they well okay this
is what they expect they should be below
this line they should be because the
universe is decelerating because of
gravity ok questions on this diagram
this is the key diagram because i'm
going to show you some real data that
looks like this everybody get that if
your dimmer you're above the line so
you're too far away if you're a brighter
you're below the line so you're closer
that's deceleration ok we're ready for
the discovery of dark energy there were
two teams who two teams actually one
team of sort of classical astronomers
one team of sort of physicists slumming
in astronomy that was a joke because
they really and this I have to show you
this picture I searched for this picture
the teams were not always shall we say
friendly when I worked at the Hubble
telescope observatory I had to oversee
the fights which were made in proposals
they weren't physical fights and these
two teams were extremely competitive but
it's a good thing they were both doing
this experiment so how did they do the
experiment they use something called a
supernova anybody know what a supernova
is yeah
it's when a son or a star explodes at
the end of its life it collapses and has
a violent explosion and becomes
extremely bright for a short period of
time here is a picture oh yeah this is
another one that's good with no lights
this is a picture of a nearby galaxies
with a supernova in it this is was this
is a supernova that was went off in 1994
so it's it's called 1994 d here's the
galaxy here what you see this is the
light from all the billions of stars in
the galaxy and here's the light of one
supernova it's very very bright compared
to most stars and you can easily see it
and it turns out that super novae make
pretty good standard candles let's uh
let's see here is the galaxy this is a
picture of a galaxy before a supernova
goes off and i'm going to show you what
it looks like when the supernova goes
off there's the supernova it's not
hugely bright in this case but you can
certainly see it above the background
dollar stellar light of the galaxy let's
do that again there's before there's
after before and after now some of you
are saying what are these bright things
maybe maybe you're asking that these
bright things unfortunately our stars in
our galaxy they we have to look through
our galaxy to look out into space and so
we always get a few stars in the way
that's what those are but this one that
peers and disappears that's a supernova
okay we can measure the brightness of
the supernova and since it's a standard
candle we know the distance to it we can
also measure its spectrum and we can
measure its redshift from the spectrum
i'm going to show you this movie which
has three parts three things going on at
once there's an image here the supernova
goes off about there you'll see it get
brighter and then dimmer as it gets
brighter than dimmer you'll see this dot
will show you how bright it is on a
light curve a light curve is the
intensity as a function of time
so as time goes on the dot will move
down here and at the same time you'll
see a movie of the spectrum the spectrum
is here and you'll see how it changes in
time so let's do this here's the
supernova going off and now getting
dimmer and that took a couple of weeks
that's like a three or four week movie
condensed for your convenience let's do
it one more time there it is getting
brighter and dimmer you see the spectrum
you see the light curve remember from
the light curve from this we're getting
the distance because it's this is saying
how bright it is and I want you to watch
the spectrum this time to see the the
absorption lines to see the spectral
lines you see all these peaks and
valleys those are what we're measuring
to get the redshift ok ok so both teams
decided to look for super and all we
have a certain kind that were standard
candles and to measure the expansion of
the universe and how it's decelerating
they used Hubble to do this there's a
big advantage to being in space let me
show you that on the left is that image
taken from a picture taken from a
ground-based telescope in very good
conditions so about the best resolution
you can get from the ground well not the
best but close it's good so this is good
resolution and this is the sharper
picture that you can take from the
Hubble Space Telescope and here you can
clearly see this is a galaxy and that's
a supernova that went off in the galaxy
and you can clearly separate them and
you can measure the supernova brightness
which is what you need whereas here it's
a little hard to see that there's
something over there it's hard to pull
it out so Hubble was really essential to
this effort ok this is the experiment
we're going to do we find standard
candles these supernovae they're called
type 1a supernovae their particular kind
we observe how bright they are to get
the distance to that supernova which of
course is in a galaxy which measures
space and we measure its redshift to get
the speed and then we plot the Hubble
diagram
and then we measure the deceleration and
we get the mass in the universe easy it
took about five years to get enough data
a big team two big teams working for
five years and as I've telegraphed they
didn't get the answer they expected
remember this is what you expect you
expect to see objects being brighter
than the constant expansion line and
here's their data the blue line is the
constant expansion line this is redshift
this is brightness distance so you can
see sure enough Hubble law and as you go
to bigger and bigger distances you're
supposed to be going down here oops it's
up here objects are dimmer than they
should have been so both teams were
highly distressed graduate students were
calculating over and over again trying
to see what they did wrong maybe the
calibrations were wrong maybe they made
a mistake somewhere because this
couldn't be true now there are some
reasons you could make up why it might
be true maybe maybe there's some screen
in front of those super novae that kind
of makes them dimmer but really what
happened was both teams talked to each
other and they found out the other guys
were having the same problem okay
actually to be honest one of the teams I
won't tell you which one one of them
actually gave a paper at a meeting
saying the universe was decelerating and
giving a measurement because they didn't
really believe their result and they
they had some points that were down here
these are been so they kind of fudged it
but then they got more data and it was
like more obvious so they compared notes
and with independent data like one team
was looking at those super novae and
another team was looking at some other
super novae so they had independent data
for the most part they found the same
result and what they concluded was that
the expansion of the universe is not
decelerating it's accelerating it's
speeding up so that galaxies are farther
away from us than they would be in a
constant expansion
1998 this was announced I think I have
the oh yeah right there to faint
accelerating there you go science
magazine put this on their cover saying
this was the breakthrough scientific
breakthrough of the year it was utterly
unexpected people didn't really believe
it at first I have to say they thought
there must be some other explanation but
within a year within a year or two there
were confirmations from let me back up a
slide yeah let me let me point something
out there were there were actually
confirmations so this red line is what
you expect if there's a force pushing
galaxies apart okay and you expect you
expect an acceleration which would go
this way how to say this okay when the
universe started its expansion it was
quite small gravity is a force that's
stronger when particles or galaxies are
close together so when the universe
started its expansion in fact gravity
was stronger than this new force which
i'm going to call dark energy and i'll
tell you why in a minute why we call it
that so when the expansion first started
it actually was slowing down but as the
universe got bigger the gravity force
between galaxies of course got weaker
because they're farther apart so the
dark energy forest seems to be pretty
constant in time so at some moment which
is about five billion years ago the
universe is 13.7 billion years old so
about five billion years ago dark energy
started winning and right now today in
our universe at this time the expansion
is accelerating and so here's the
critical point if the supernova were too
faint for some other reason having to do
with you know they were formed earlier
in the universe or something then you
should expect to see this black line
where as you go farther away they just
get dimmer and dimmer but
if it indeed there is some kind of dark
energy then you expect this expansion to
have been decelerating at some point so
it would fall below the constant rate
line at very large distances very large
red shifts very large speeds and this is
what was seen in fact points were seen
over here and that absolutely clinched
it you can't explain it by all the
reasons people were giving it had to be
some kind of new stuff new force that
was pushing spaced-apart this is pretty
radical you grew up learning maybe about
gravity maybe you learned about
electricity and magnetism if you took
physics advanced physics you might have
learned about the weak force and the
strong force we've known about those for
almost 100 years this is something new
and in 2001 the new nasa spacecraft
called w map measured how much of this
stuff there was and its most of the
universe i should explain about
Einsteins blunder so Einstein of course
he he came up with his theory of gravity
also a hundred years ago in the 19-teens
and at that time astronomers hadn't yet
Hubble hadn't yet had his insight that
the universe was expanding astronomers
thought the universe was completely
static now this was dumb we now realize
because it you know physics would have
told us otherwise and and Einstein
realized that if you had a static
universe with galaxies everywhere it
should be contracting because of gravity
but his astronomers told him it was not
contracting so he thought he scratched
his head he said gee my equations say
gravity should be making it fall in but
but they tell me it's not so I need
another force pushing out so he put a
number in his acquit he put a constant
called lambda capital Greek letter
lambda into his equations to oppose
gravity so that the universe could be
static now when Hubble said
the universe is expanding then Einstein
said oh I was completely wrong because
if the universe is expanding it can be
slowing down okay but but but Einsteins
laws work great without the constant
without the lambda so he said that was
just stupid that I put that in my
equations and I should never have done
it he called it his greatest blunder
actually he didn't say that gamma said
that gamma off said you know Einstein
was talking to me and he said this was
my greatest blunder but now in 1998 this
stuff this dark energy behaves exactly
like Einsteins lambda very annoying
because it was not a it was not a good
suggestion to have a lambda but now
people have found it okay that's a
little you can you can think what you
want about that let me skip this I can
come back if you're interested what
causes this acceleration as I told you
we call it dark energy let me explain
the term dark well energy let me do
energy first energy because it's causing
something to push out okay that's why
it's called energy it's sort of opposite
of gravity in a way dark in astronomy
and physics means we don't know what it
is okay dark energy means we don't see
it we see its effects it's dark to us
but we see its effects in the couple
plot that I showed you some of you ever
heard of dark matter as well it's it's
different dark matter is extra stuff we
don't see that causes positive gravity
the only thing they share is that word
dark and dark means we don't know what
it is okay they do opposite things Dark
Matter pulls in dark energy pushes out
okay what is it don't know how much is
there we do know that it's three
quarters of the universe what causes it
no idea how does it behave we're working
on it we are doing experiments now to
map the expansion history of the
universe and to try to see if the
drinks of dark energy has changed over
time and how much and that tells us
something about where it comes from for
those of you who have had physics you
can think of it as a sort of potential
energy much like the inflation potential
that caused the initial expansion of the
universe okay here's our pie chart of
the universe three quarters dark energy
unknown before 1998 astronomers solving
the last final problem discovers
something basically discovered they
hadn't known anything before in your
class your science class it's probably
bad to discover something you didn't
know before because you're supposed to
you know write down the right answer on
the test but in science this is actually
fabulous if you find that you are wrong
but it means as you learn something new
and what we learn is really interesting
there's this whole other force out there
that we didn't know about and it's most
of the universe we are made of what I
call normal matter this stuff sometimes
you hear the term baryonic matter that's
protons neutrons atoms like in the
periodic table which there probably
should be one in this building it's
behind the screen that's normal matter
we're made of a lot of water a lot of
carbon so there's hydrogen oxygen carbon
some other stuff phosphorous nitrogen
things you're familiar with that's a
tiny fraction that everything except
hydrogen helium we call heavy elements
that's point oh three percent of the
universe so what we're made of what the
earth is made of everything we know how
to measure in the laboratory and play
with it demonstrations that stuff is
negligibly present in our universe most
of its dark energy a great deal it is
something called dark matter I explained
to you that that's those are particles
that interact they have gravity they
cause gravity they cause galaxies to
stick together and and they do pull on
each other but we don't know what it's
made of its some particle that is not
described by our current law
of physics there are some ideas about
what it might be if you've heard of the
Large Hadron Collider they might be as
studying it but we don't know yet what
it is okay I'm going to skip this and
I'm just going to end you can ask me
about geometry later I just want to end
with a few words about what are we going
to do so the first thing is what's the
fate of the universe we don't know okay
it used to be pretty easy you could just
measure how much mass was in it and that
would tell you whether it was going to
expand forever or turn around and fall
back in not easy anymore because now we
have two effects we have gravity pulling
in we have dark energy pushing out and
we don't know which is going to win so
this cartoon kind of gives you some some
of the theories that are out there we
don't know what's correct the universe
could expand forever and we could end up
a sort of cold dark universe where most
of us are living inside black holes it
could if dark energy goes away in time
you could end up with gravity pulling
everything back in or if dark energy
gets stronger it could rip apart
galaxies and stars and eventually
anybody we don't know which it is we're
going to go to telescopes and look
here's here's just a few this is the win
telescope in Arizona you can visit it if
you're out at kitt peak near tucson this
is this is a telescope that Yale owns
part of that's the why that's Yale
Wisconsin Indiana Yale and the National
optical Astronomy observatories we were
actually the last partner they had a
nice acronym it was wi n win and we were
the last so we should go on the end but
then we'd be whiny so we put ourselves
here we also Gale also has a part of the
Keck telescopes which are on mon achaean
on the big island in hawaii and what
you're looking at here are the two
telescope domes for the Keck and behind
as a japanese telescope called super
subaru
Hawaii it can be kind of wet it rains
there clouds but the clouds are below
the top of the mountain so you can go to
Hawaii can be pouring rain and the
astronomers are observing it's really
fun I was there a few weeks ago doing
that this is the end of my talk it's not
the end of the story there's a huge
thing to discover and understand and
what's really amazing to me is just a
few astronomers using a few telescopes
and getting a few bits of light from
distant galaxies can figure this out can
figure out billions of years of cosmic
history and i hope i invite you younger
people to learn more about this when you
get back to your classes thank you